và anh có tin chúng ta đã mắt phải một sai lâm to đúng.
Giang Việt Nam không thực sự lình ở một nè cú thể tỏ không?
Nhưng tỏ nhá, lâu tin, phải nói về thử mà cả thị dưới đang uống hàng ngày.
Đó chính là cả phê.
Để só tan hiểu lâm đó, hãy nhìn vào sự kiện tuyên trọn Cafe Robusta Tòn Cầu,
O Đez One, hàng in không trăm 2 mi bốn.
ZOGCEF, lên đoàn tinh hoang, ngày gà phê đạ Trung Hoa, tổ chức,
có một thương hiểu việc đã làm nên điều kiếp, Erucco Coffee.
Dưới một sự kiện quy tụ tới bá nghìn nắm trong người tham gia đình giá.
Tự các chuyên gia hàng đầu đến barista chuyên nghiệp cùng các cơ quan kìm định xin sò,
từ đại loan, mặt cao, malaysia, singa por, mesico và indunisia.
Với qua tám nhìn đối thủ, là các cường quốc cafe trên thế giới.
Erucco Coffee đã vô trang đặt giải, top Robusta Ngon nhất Tòn Cầu,
tại GCEF, hàng in không trăm 2 mi bốn.
Khẳng định lánh thép giang, nông sản Việt thực sự có chậu đừng vướng chắc trên chương quốc tế.
Vì thế ấy, cơn được bảo chứng bởi chụi thành tích được bà.
Vô định đã rava viết ca, năm hàng in không trăm 2 mi người.
Vì sau tám mi sau phải sau ba điểm, cùng tám năm linh tiếp đã trứng nhận cafe đặc xa,
tại Việt Nam ở may sinh khắp và mới đây nhất từ hào vừa lên vị trí,
top mode, arabica, tại Việt Nam Coffee Produce Competition,
hàng in không trăm 2 mi sau, vừa điểm sau tám mi tám điểm.
Đắp ứng chọn bộ tiêu chừng bằng câu từ rainforest alliance, Mỹ,
Bốn xe, được, ha làn FDIUSA, HACCP đến ISO 2 mi 2 nghiên.
Airical Coffee đã xuất khẩu sát mười tị trường khó tính,
New Me, Anh, Đức, Oak, Tây Banh nhà, Singapore, Malaysia, Trung Quốc,
Đại Loan, Nhật Bà, Chứng miếng tâm bóng tức sử của hạt vạn nung sản Việt,
và hôm nay để bà cũng thể tự mình kiểm chứng và hử gấm niềm tin chong vẻng và nung sản nước nhà.
Già không caffei uite like, Co-Brill Arabica, Đặc xa, Airical đã sẵn sáng để được tình thích
được uại chạp xuất nhiều dở.
Co-Brill Arabica chắt lọc nêm vị trua nhẹ,
thỏng hơn qua tự nhiên, cùng hậu viện ngọt sâu lắm để mẹ hoặc.
Không đường, ít ca lọc và một trong phần trọng quyền chát,
cùng lăn toa ra chị bình vướng cho cà phê viện,
bởi nung sản Việt Nam thức sử lịch và sân đáng toa sáng hơn nữa.